President Trump and other top officials
denies saying many of the things that
appear in Bob Woodward's explosive new
book on the administration fear Trump in
the White House shows the president
lashing out at high-ranking aides while
staffers tried to control mr. Trump's
impulses White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders says the book is full of
quote fabricated stories and said the
president's approach through
unconventionally always gets the results
David Martin has read the book and has
spoken to Bob Woodward he's at the White
House David good morning good morning
Woodward's book published by Simon &
Schuster a division of CBS describes the
White House as a quote zoo without walls
where aides feared not what the
president might do to them but what he
might do to the country White House
chief of staff John Kelly who spends
more time with the president than any
other official thinks he is unhinged
according to Woodward who writes that in
one small group meeting Kelley said he's
an idiot it's pointless to try and
convince him of anything he's gone off
the rails responding Tuesday Kelley
called that account not true last year
Kelley said being chief of staff is the
hardest job he's ever had it is not the
best job I ever had
Kelley is quoted by Woodward as
repeating that sentiment saying we're in
crazy town this is the worst job I've
ever had
he's very thrilled not to see rockets
going over Japan according to Woodward
defense secretary James Mathers told
close associates the president acted
like and had the understanding of a
fifth or sixth grader the barbaric
killing of small and helpless children
and babies must be forcefully rejected
after the president saw a video of the
aftermath of a poison gas attack on
Syrian civilians in April 2017
he called mattis and according to
Woodward fumed
let's expletive kill him referring to
Syria's dictator Bashar al-assad Mathers
said he would get right on it but told a
senior aide we're not going to do any of
that
in a statement mattis said those words
were never uttered by me according to
Woodward the president also refers to
his attorney general as
mentally [ __ ] and also according to
Woodward said he's this dumb southerner
Tuesday evening the president denied
that account adding that Woodward made
this up to divide earlier in the day
speaking to the Daily Caller president
Trump claimed Woodward had a lot of
credibility problems and on Twitter
wondered whether Woodward is a
democratic operative would were tried
but was not granted an interview with
mr. Trump and in a brief phone
conversation last month
Woodward warned him what was coming the
tough look at the world and your
administration and you right well I
assume that means it's going to be a
negative book Woodward also reports the
president's former attorney John Dowd
felt he would commit perjury if
interviewed by the special counsel doubt
felt the President had nothing to hide
but also believed he was a quote
expletive liar on capable of giving a
simple factual statement doubt issued a
statement last night denying he had ever
called the president a liar Norah
David Bob Woodward basis this book in
his reporting on hundreds of hours of
tapes with these sources many of them
who spoke on deep background I know
since you spent time and have known Bob
Woodward for many years perhaps
explained sort of how he does his
reporting to sort of circle in on this
narrative of what's happening inside the
White House well first place the ground
rules for his interviews are deep
background which means he can use the
information but not the names of the
people he's interviewing he taped
records all of the interviews those
interviews are transcribed by an
assistant and that is his primary source
as he begins working on a book but in
the course of those interviews he also
gets these people to turnover Diaries
and notes they kept during their time in
office so he is working from a wealth of
material and we should point out that
after some of the White House
denunciations of the book came out
yesterday Bob Woodward issued a
statement saying he stands by his
reporting
David there is always backbiting and
palace intrigue in any White House this
account of this White House is
extraordinarily different because it
paints the president as incompetent in
many ways specifically the accounts
there's a lot by the defense secretary
Jim mattis has you you know does not do
many interviews since you cover the
Pentagon in one particular exchange
which you just hit on the president
questioned why we have troops on the
Korean Peninsula to which the defense
secretary said we are trying to prevent
World War three do you believe that the
defense secretary spoke with Bob
Woodward on deep background no and in
fact I know he didn't speak with Bob
Woodward on on any ground goals but
mattis comes across here as sort of the
Trump whisperer in this administration
the the one official who somehow knows
how to handle Trump and he does that
whatever the president says you have a
good point mr. president your instincts
are correct but let's try and do it this
way and the bottom line is the US has
not withdrawn from any military
alliances and the u.s. has not engaged
in any reckless military operations
overseas all right David great to have
you this morning thank you so much and
only on CBS you can watch David's full
interview with Bob Woodward that's this
Sunday on CBS Sunday morning